you keep so i ньютон випусти покарає ще
не хоче, а нова холодний вин з росію
і на мажорній новій холодній війні
протестую позицій менше шести
вуса вказано на я вниз холодної війни то
що каламутний ви знаєте ланцюги calls on open
і як би ми не встань і холодної війни
частота чоловіка травня конфронтації
між будинками позовним та блоками краї нам
і варшавського договору то нато
варшавського договору в за шини galibier
травня радецького союзу наводжуся я точно з
але й
такі росія влаштуватися до цієї на гаю
оружі не сша влаштуватися паджа ша алла
russian r1 ский союз а варшавського
договору за galibier шина ясна і тему
плані без пкм і в Європі розумні простому
виконаному ви ікла в аточі не
розуміємо цього партнерства і до
намазалася вийнятої після завершення
холодної провини
червоним айнов стане холодної війни акції
було до падіння берлінського муру
холоду хворий гол поговоримо про
прагнення по вам знайду ж вдається з 3
мод і втомимося годиною особливо його у випад
кус криму та україну на жаль ви не чавуни
в роби оп і за побивши ти веселий
операції росії в криму геть обламалося
від через між іржавий кордон вона-то
налити на передачу все в ньому of any
найменшого у яблуні щець і стогнати а у
купити не минуло уроку кілочки [ __ ]
командувати влаштованих сонату дізнався
критичніше прогалини у зборі.
даних на ту
деки весь килим аршані росії сказав
він застала нас ниночка вона шоу бізнес
несе активності Росії на території
україна була досить шалену
хибачі нашу купу прогнала нашу купу
критично прогалин збору та аналізу а
висловить і ще я захисну силу
вам сліди розумі ти різницю між
зануренням свого основного завдання
а сам і запечатаю броня ти всіх союзників
в палату і ми роба moze сьогодні за
забезпечуємо він одну з вимог шляхом
кримінальна причина, щоб вона стала
сюжетного на подана кіготь і пошила
нього також мало швидким через грозу
ми руту стабільності у світяться було б
нечесно завантажити шини цього у але я ви
кінні свою роботу збираюся на
первинний атлантичний дога wear pick &
eus нову альянсу і забув я за ним
а то захищатися і лають і вусик
союзників по нато
ви говорили про свій паркан я за неї
перед членами нато закрий мізки на 10 5
крапель велика ще на під на одну
україну роз'їдається і вікна під на всіх
проте чит-код зрозуміло ви не можете
викладати ці в'язання взагалі по
глянути і прикладом на балтійські країни
тайської гри столітті проводять пентагон то й
нічого вашингтоні засвічуся ще ви
значно прогрійте перед лицем буде
кований нас тупо росії на балтику ви не
можете завести ти болта коп cw всі скроні
і гра вашингтона не може, а ви куди ти
забув я за неї вийти це ми можемо а ви
куди ти забув я зайнятий можемо азаді щоб
програми у всіх ризикових іграх.
прорвав ще раз за кулер і тигровий
такі сценарії про провал не просто
води базу та ціна у площі ще ми не
можемо знову відрахування свою нитку там тепер
при суть не весь каната ми збили шила
нашу злочинницю з видного району
альянсу за допомогою батальйону у брата -
твердіше йому ще батальйоні стати
несе за і сором і балтійські держави нам
потрібні національні з броні сили
балтійських держав аламо бути найбільшим
нам потреба дати не сенату змит з
його тис а заради потреби
if needed